james guns a suicide squad is so
action-packed that you might not believe
anything was left out but in reality
there were many scenes we didn't get to
see here are the scenes that didn't make
the cut
as the suicide squad begins rig flag is
not paired up with his eventual team
instead he's stuck with a squadron of
supervillains that amanda waller has
sent in as cannon fodder to distract
enemy forces their mission does not go
well everyone is exploding genitals
heads arms legs in the theatrical cut
the viewer assumes flag has been
assigned to this doomed unit simply due
to warlord's cold attitude toward human
life but originally a now deleted scene
was meant to add extra context to flag's
presence on this team gunn explained how
the scene would have happened in an
interview with the script apart podcast
where rick flagg makes fun of amanda
waller's shirt and you just see death in
biola's face like she just looks like
that and that's that's why he's on that
beach considering the successful track
record of jokes in the suicide squad an
extra darker gag like this would have
been more than welcome
throughout the suicide squad audiences
aren't left wanting when it comes to
action beats involving characters like
ratcatcher 2 or polka dot man these
obscure figures from the comics get
several opportunities to establish
themselves as memorable to the general
public at one point though there were
plans to feature these two fan favorite
characters in another extended action
sequence gun told collider there's a
whole section with rat catcher and king
shark and polka dot man and thinker that
i cut that was pretty dynamite stuff but
it was taking our time at the wrong
point in the film so it was a good cut
it hurts but that's how movie making is
though this scene was left on the
cutting room floor at least moviegoers
aren't entirely deprived of action
moments from rats catcher 2 and polka
dot man in the final cuts of the suicide
squad
while bloodsport and the rest of the
suicide squad take a bus ride to about
the thinker frequence most of these
super villains are lost in their
thoughts but not king shark he's staring
out the window enamored with the
denizens of corto maltese king shark's
captivation of these sights of everyday
people connecting makes it apparent that
this toothy fellow isn't just a dim wet
with muscles there's sorrow within this
beast fueled by a burning desire to be
connected to other people originally
though this quiet poignant moment was
not the only indicator of king shark's
internal desires james gunn initially
had plans to build on this moment and
further explore the character's
loneliness gunn told collider that
actually was a much longer sort of
montage that is really beautiful and i
really like it in and of itself again it
was at the wrong place in the movie
what adversary should a pack of super
villains fight in the final cut of the
suicide squad a series of contenders
ranging from quartzo maltese generals to
the alien star ro the conqueror serve as
opponents for bloodsport and company but
there was once an iteration of guns the
suicide squad that saw these morally
troubled characters confronting not
another dc comics baddie but one of the
most iconic superheroes of all time
superman there was a time when i thought
the suicide squad should fight superman
that they should have to get superman i
thought that was a very interesting
story instead of superman government
with a personal favorite character star
wrote the conqueror as a principal
antagonist gunn explained he's a
character i love from the comics i think
he's a perfect comic book character
because he's absolutely ludicrous but
also very scary in his own way starfish
is a slang term for a butthole think
there's any connection shortly before
the release of the suicide squad james
gunn took to twitter to reveal the dc
comics baddies that he attempted to put
into the film but couldn't find a space
for among those listed was deathstroke a
dark character who was previously played
by joe main janello in justice league
while most of these characters were
revealed with no context as to how they
would have factored into the suicide
squad a behind the scenes featurette
shed some light on deathstroke's
potential role in the featurette the
suicide squad the way of the gun the
director speaks to a room of artists
with various pieces of concept art
staple to the wall behind him among this
collection of images is one depicting
deathstroke at the head of the suicide
squad gun has been open about the fact
that the position of suicide squad
frontman was written for idris elba
first and foremost in the early stages
the director just didn't know who he
would play the concept dart indicates
that for at least a while deathstroke
was a potentially prominent player in
the suicide squad as a candidate for the
elba role that would eventually take the
form of bloodsport james gunn also
revealed that it considered using
another established dceu character as
well black manta who previously appeared
in aquaman however any scenes involving
black manta in the suicide squad didn't
get far into the production on twitter
gunn revealed that while he quote
considered black manta he decided
against it because manta's power set
didn't quite work with the vision he had
placing the importance of storytelling
above cinematic universe connections
speaks to the kind of sharp discerning
writing that made the final cut of the
suicide squad so much fun to watch
the finale of the suicide squad features
plenty of cathartic moments like harley
quinn finally figuring out what she
should do with the javelin she's been
carrying around and ratcatcher 2
channelling the spirit of her father to
summon an army of rodents but it's not
all triumph and exciting action there's
also a crushing moment meant to
reinforce the gravity of the movie's
villain when polka dot man gets crushed
by starro just moments after he finally
feels like a superhero for the first
time interestingly polka dot man wasn't
always going to get the star squish gun
explained to variety the original ending
that i pitched to one main character
died and one main character did not die
and the main character who died was rat
catcher 2. she was so sweet i just felt
like it was just too dark not that we
don't love polka dot man we do i just
couldn't so i relented given that
ratcatcher 2 has become such a fan
favorite character since our suicide
squad debuted it's likely gunn made the
right call
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]